ultimately there is that message that
these kids took a leap of faith had a
lot of courage to go out and find out
who they are
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason TV and
today we're talking with Jenny Lynn
Merton and Tyler Mason the directors of
the highly acclaimed movie sons of
perdition thanks for joining us explain
what your movies about and why somebody
should say it
well our film sons of perdition details
the lives of three boys who were exiled
from their polygamous community of
Colorado City Arizona headquarters and
home of the FLDS of which fundamentalist
latter-day saints which is an offshoot
of the LDS the Mormon faith they don't
the Mormon Church the mainstream Mormon
Church is no longer practice polygamy
their prophet and leader Warren Jeffs
had a kind of a tight-fisted iron-fisted
rule over this community and for the
last X amount of years they've been
they've been kicking teenage boys out of
the community and these boys have little
to no education no contact with the
outside world and pretty much one day
they're thrust out into the world they
know very little about why are they
being kicked out well that's kind of a
tricky sort of question in a quandary
that we dealt with in the film I mean
you know some arguments are that they're
being kicked out because it's a numbers
game I mean if you've got to have more
than one wife to get into heaven then
you have a math problem so there is some
of that but you know because Warren
Jeffs themselves has probably over 80
wives and you know the leaders of the
church have more wives but some of the
sort of you know researchers and other
people contend that it's more about
obedience and so they sort of you know
push them to the edge and kind of force
them out so some are literally kicked
out some are just their lives are made
miserable and they're marginalized and
they
go so I mean you get rid of the
troublemakers or the likely trouble
matters yeah and you get rid of anybody
that's not gonna completely toe the line
keep the traditions and you know commit
crimes for you can you describe the
scene where one of the female characters
in the film 14 year old Hillary is
choosing between a cop and her and her
sister and family in a mall parking lot
what's what's going on well one of the
main characters of the film Joe he's out
and he left on his own recognizance he
um he really wants his family to come
out and that includes his mother and his
14 year old sister Hillary and in this
particular scene she's spotted by us and
the boys at a mall with her older sister
and she wants to leave and she makes a
notion to her you know the kids I want
to go I want to go I want to go so Sam
who's another character in the film
calls the police the police come and
show up and they they ask her do you
want to go and she says yes I want to
leave now her older sister Sabrina who
is also in the polygamous community does
not want her to leave and is under
orders from her father not to let her go
so she literally holds one arm while the
police officer has the other arm of this
poor little 14 year old girl and we as
filmmakers are shooting this from across
the parking lot what's it like to be
filming that as a you know I mean what
what were you feeling I mean in that
particular case it was you know it was
very frightening because we we had to
you know we got involved enough that we
were actually concerned you know we were
concerned about what was literally
having happening there with the kids but
not just filming it
but you know you're trying to hide from
the police this is how they don't see
you shooting and you are trying to
capture a really you know sort of
frightening moment so you're kind of I
mean so we did a lot of sort of hidden
shooting and had to kind of hide and you
know and there was I mean you know
there's this moment where you know
Sabrina looks right at us and it's hard
to keep the shot right there you know I
mean you have to you have to take some
some risks
what what is the threat posed by the
FLDS in your opinion to a kind of ideal
of religious freedom in America well I
wouldn't say it's I mean yeah is it a
threat to religious freedom they
practice what they want and that is one
of the beauties of America I suppose but
are they breaking laws yeah absolutely
are they finding ways to subjugate those
laws finding little loopholes do they
marry do they marry more than one wife
no actually they don't legally they
don't they legally marry one woman and
then they spirit marry the others so and
and are they breaking laws in in the
state of Utah in Arizona you can be
married at 15 as long as the parents
have give permission to do so
and of course that's a law that goes
back hundreds of years so they're not
necessarily breaking the law and they've
found ways to find loopholes but are
they breaking the law in many ways yes
absolutely well I think it's I think
it's a challenge to freedom of religion
in the sense that if we if they are an
example of the rights to have the
freedom of religion and this is the way
that it is being treated and then it
becomes a Tiger tug of war it you know
legislatively and and you know
culturally then yeah then it becomes a
problem because it's sort of saying all
right we've given our freedoms and this
is the way that we're going to exercise
them then we do then we have a problem
and it brings up the issue of to what
extent can you can you and should you
exercise those and I you know I think
it's kind of in a way creates a blight
on that freedom what what brought you to
this particular topic well Jenny and I
were both ex-mormons which is different
from being FLDS of course and the
official Mormon Church or the the Salt
Lake City based main Church does not
recognize how felt yes not at all no no
they you know and came out in one of
their conference speeches you know years
ago and just said we have absolutely
nothing to do with them do you guys buy
that or is there an on the wink or is it
definitely well yeah absolutely I mean
did they did they create the mess yeah
they did did they practice plug-in here
previously absolutely although that I
mean they officially gave that up as
part of doctrine as a cost of entry into
the Union exactly yeah in 1890 they said
no longer practice polygamy and that was
part of being able to gain statehood as
a state of Utah
what is that what's the kind of larger
reach of the movie
if there is one what's what's it say
about being young in in contemporary
America probably the biggest sort of
message for us was sometimes you have to
make a huge leap of faith to leave your
faith and you have to sometimes
sacrifice a whole lot to find out who
you are and so it might be leaving your
family it might be you know coming out
of the closet it might be choosing to be
a filmmaker an artist when your family
says you know forget it you'll never
make it don't do it and so I think for
us that sort of underlying message is
you know fight for who you want to be
and I think that's something that
everybody can whether you're interested
in the kind of like you know unless
you're details of polygamy in the
curiosity but ultimately there is that
message that these kids took a leap of
faith had a lot of courage to go out and
find out who they are and it doesn't
matter if you're from Colorado City it
doesn't matter if you're from the slums
it doesn't matter if you're from the
swamps of Louisiana or from Orange
County California it doesn't matter you
can be born with a feel-good message
it's a coming-of-age story yeah talk
talk about the kids in the film what
what kind of future do they have in a
post flds world do they have you know
will they be able to make it or what's
what's going to happen to them well I
think first and foremost is that they
just they don't have the religion it
takes or I'm sorry not the religion but
the education it takes to survive in a
modern world just the basics they don't
have you know the man landed on the moon
they don't know modern history they
don't know checking accounts they just
don't know how to survive
rock and roll yeah they don't know
modern media they don't know anything
like that so so that alone and just your
basics your basic English skills your
basic writing skills how to fill out a
job application or a resume no idea
whatsoever and those basics really keep
them and and also just the schooling you
know they try to get into school but
when you've never gone to school for the
most part you really don't even know how
to do it and so they try and get in this
but it scares them they've never made
decisions they've never been able they
this is what you wore this is when you
ate this is the job you're gonna have
this is the wife you're gonna have this
is the house you're gonna have and then
one day they have every decision right
in front of them Millions and they don't
know how to make those decisions well I
want to thank you and best of luck on
sons of perdition for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie and we've been talking with
Jenny Lynn Merton and Tyler Mesa thanks
very much